AND TKACHUK.
FACE OFF AGAINST THE GET THEM G.
LOOK AT THE SCORED.
HAGEL FIRES AGAINST FLAMES AND N
HE COMES OUT WITH THElause ]
RELENTLESS BY RICHARDSON.
HERE IS THE HIGH SHORTT FEEDS P.
>> LET'S TAKETEERED HIGH.
TURNED INTO THREE ON TWO.
GAUDREAU STILL GOT A
WORK BY COLEMAN.
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
TANEVCAN LEAGUE
WHEN JEREMY WAS LET GO. DEEP.
MARKSTROM STICK HANDLING.
POPPED UP.
THEY SCORE.
GIVEN AWAY A MAKES THE NICE
PLAY TONCAT DOWN THE WING WITH
A PASS ACROSS.
HERE IS A CHANCE.
MARKST GAME TYING GOAL
AND MICE PLAY BY DEBRINCAT. AHE.
DACH.. SPOTS KANE
AND WATCH THE SAVE BY MARKSTROM.
GETS A LITTLE BIT OF IT.
AND THEN OFF THE POST GREAT GUY.
RASMUS ANDERSSON GOING TO THROW
IT AT THE NET.
THERE IS JOHNNY OF LOVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MIGHT BE TWO ON ONE.
TOEWS BACK.
HAGEL IN FRONT.
TOEWS HAG IT IN FRONT.
GETS A LITTLE BIT OF PROSPECT.
AND PATRICK
PUCK COME TO MCCABE.
RIPS IT AROUND THE BOARDS.
>> HERE IS TANEV IN TIGHT.
THE B B PRETTY GOOD LESSON
FOR GOALTENDERS.
MARC-ANDRÉ FLEURY NOT HAPPY AT
ALL WITH THE OVER SHOT
OFF THE SHOULDER OF FLEURY.
GOODET.
LUCIC LETS IT ROLL IN FROM
CENTRE ICE.
AND THAT NET.
WATCH LUCIC SHIELD
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> THAT MAKES IT 5-2 IT.
MATTHEW TKACHUK GET PRESSURE
HELP FROM LINDHOLM.
AND D